Oh world,
it's Saroj and let's build a chat Bot
that can answer questions about any texts
you give it, be it an article
or even a book using care Os.
Just imagine the boost in productivity.
All of us we'll have,
once we have access to expert
systems for any given topic,
instead of sifting through all
the jargon in a scientific paper,
you just give it the paper, then ask it
the relevant questions, entire textbooks,
libraries, videos, images, whatever.
You just feed it some data and
it would become an expert at it.
All 7 billion people on Earth would
have the capability of learning anything
much faster.
The web democratize information and
this next evolution will democratize
something just as important guidance,
the ideal chatbox and talk intelligently
about any domain. That's the holy grail.
But domain specific chatbots
are definitely possible.
The technical term for this is a
question answering system. Surprisingly,
we've been able to do this since way back
in the 70s. Lunar was one of the first.
It was, as you might've
guessed, rural based.
So it allowed geologists to ask questions
about moon rocks from the Apollo
missions.
Uh,
later improvement to rule based QA
systems allowed programmers to encode
patterns into their Bot called artificial
intelligence markup language or AI ml.
That meant less code for the same results,
but yeah, don't use AI ml. It's so old.
It makes Numa Numa look new.
Now with deep learning,
we can do this without hardcoded
responses and have much better results.
The generic case is that you give it
some docs as input and then ask it a
question. It'll give you the right answer
after logically reasoning about it.
The input could also be that everybody
is happy and then the question could be
what's the sentiment? The answer would be
positive. Other possible questions are,
what's the entity?
What are the part of speech tags?
What's the translation to French?
We need a common model for
all of these questions.
This is what the Ai community is
trying to figure out how to do.
Facebook research made some great
progress with this just two years ago when
they released a paper introducing this
really cool idea called a memory network.
LSTM networks proved to be a useful
tool in tasks like tech summarization,
but their memory is encoded by hidden
states and weights is too small for very,
very long sequences of data
be that a book or a movie,
a way around this for language
translation for example,
was to store multiple LSTM states and
use an attention mechanism to choose
between them,
but they developed another strategy that
outperform an LSTM for Q and a systems.
The idea was to allow a neural network
to use an external data structure as
memory storage.
It learns where to retrieve their
required memory from the memory bank in a
supervised way.
When it came to answering questions from
[inaudible] data that was generated,
that Info was pretty easy to come by. But
in real world data, it is not that easy.
Most recently there was a four month
long Kaggle contest that a startup called
metamind place in the top 5% four.
To do this,
they built a new state of the art model
called a dynamic memory network that
built on Facebook's initial idea.
That's the one we'll focus on.
So let's build it programmatically
using care Os. This dataset,
it's pretty well organized.
It was created by Facebook AI research
for the specific goal of improving
textual reasoning.
It's grouped into 20 different tasks.
Each task test a different
aspect of reasoning,
so overall it provides a good overview
of all the different capabilities of your
learning model.
There are a thousand questions
for training and a thousand
for testing per task.
Each question is paired with a statement
or a series of statements as well as an
answer. The goal is to have one model
that can succeed in all tasks easily.
We'll use pretrained glove vectors to
help create a sequence of word vectors
from our input sentences and these
vectors will act as inputs to the model.
The DMN and architecture defines two
types of memory, semantic and episodic.
These input vectors are
considered the semantic memory,
whereas episodic memory may
contain other knowledge as well,
and we'll talk about that in a second.
We can fetch our babbled Dataset from
the web and split them into training and
testing.
Data glove will help convert our words
to vectors so they're ready to be fed
into our model.
The first module,
the input module is a gru or gated
recurrent unit that runs on a sequence of
word vectors.
A Gru cell is kind of like an LSTM cell,
but it's more computationally efficient
since it only has two gates and it
doesn't use a memory unit.
The two gates control when it's content
is updated and when it's erased.
A recent update,
recent update or recent,
and the hidden state of the input module
represents the input process so far in
a vector.
It outputs hidden states after every
sentence and he's outputs are called facts
in the paper because they represent
the essence of what is fed.
Given a word vector and the previous time
step director will compute the current
time step vector. The update gate
is a single layer neural network.
We sum up the Matrix multiplications
and add a bias term and then the sigmoid
squashes it to a list of values
between zero and one the output vector.
We do this twice with
different sets of weights.
Then we use a reset gate that we'll
learn to ignore the past time steps when
necessary.
For example,
if the next sentence has nothing to
do with those that came before it,
the uptake gate is similar in that it
can learn to ignore the current time step
entirely. Maybe the current sentence
has nothing to do with the answer,
whereas previous ones did.
Then there's the question module.
It processes the question word by word
and I'll put a vector by using the same
gru as the input module
and the same weights.
We can encode both of them by
creating embedding layers for both.
Then we'll create an episodic
memory representation.
Both the motivation for this in the paper
came from the hippocampus function in
our brain.
It's able to retrieve can portal states
that are triggered by some response,
like a sight or a sound,
both the fact and questioned vectors that
are extracted from the input enter the
episodic memory module.
It's composed of two nested.
You are use the energy are you
generate what are called episodes.
It does this by passing over
the facts from the input module,
but when updating it's interstate,
it takes into account the output of an
attention function. On the current fact,
the attention function gives a score
between zero and one to each fact and so
the gru ignores facts with low scores
after each full pass on all the facts,
the energy are you outputs an episode
which is then fed to the outer gru.
The reason we need multiple episodes is
so our model can learn what part of a
sentence it should pay attention to.
After realizing after one pass,
that's something else is important.
With multiple passes,
we can gather increasingly
relevant information.
We can initialize our model and set
its loss function as categorical cross
entropy with the stochastic gradient
descent implementation rms prop.
Then train it on the given
data using the fit function.
We can test this code in the browser
without waiting for it to train because
luckily for us,
this researcher uploaded a web app with
a fully trained model of this code.
We can generate a story which is a
collection of sentences each describing an
event in sequential order.
Then we'll ask it a question.
Pretty high accuracy response.
Let's generate another story and ask
it another question. Hero status.
Let's go over the three
key facts we've learned.
Gru is control the flow of data like
LSTM cells but are more computationally
efficient using just two gates.
Update and reset.
Dynamic memory networks offer state of
the art performance in question answering
systems and they do this by using both
semantic and episodic memory inspired by
the hippocampus. Drum
roll please. Nevermind.
Nemanja told Meek is decoding
challenge winner from last week.
He implemented his own neural machine
translator by training it on movie
subtitles in both English and German.
You can see all the results
in his eye python notebook.
Amazing work wizard of the week
and the runner up is Michelle Batu.
Despite the massive amount of
training time and empty requires,
Michelle was able to achieve some
great results. I vow to both of you.
This week's challenge is to
make your own Q and a chat bot.
All the details are in the read me get
humbling links going to comments and all
announce a winner a week from today.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos, check out this related video,
and for now I've got to ask the right
questions, so thanks for watching.